et voici sa zot caddie avec bertrand
caruge et son invité bonjour bertrand
bonjour dhimmi bonjour à tout le monde
et bonjour grippe a va des bons joueurs
reviendront caruge bonjour aux auditeurs
et auditrices de martinique la première
vous êtes directeur général chez solly a
anti une agence immobilière sociale et
vous êtes venu nous parler du programme
est dont le but est l'accompagnement des
ménages dans la réduction des factures
énergétiques tant en haut qu'en
électricité alors d'abord garip ayvaz 17
acronis mme cet acronyme plutôt est ce
n'est pas que pour faire un bon jeu de
mots 1 en allusion à la pelure des
agrumes et puis le bon geste est geste
le bons gestes à adopter non ça
correspond donc à un nom bien précis
d'une action bien précises résumé donc
dans ce terme est c'est quoi ça veut
dire si c'est la zone
alors laconi m'échappe là sur le coup
mais alors outre-mer solidaire voit la
transition énergétique voilà voilà voilà
ok alors donc ça fait un an à travers ce
programme est que vous accompagnez une
vingtaine de familles au départ c'est ça
non ça vient ça fait non çà çà çà çà a
commencé si vous voulez par par un
diagnostic ces six actions en fait se
décline en six actions et en fait les
deux premières actions ne concerne pas
les ménages directement du tai shan un
diagnostic et puis d'animation
territoriale
mais pour le coup aujourd'hui à quatre
autres actions en fait qui concerne
directement les ménages qui sont des
ateliers collectifs des bilans éco
gestes des des échos travaux en fait et
au final un bilan un suivi de la
consommation énergétique alors ça c'est
depuis un an que vous faites ça oui
c'est depuis un an c'est à dire qu'on a
une seconde de retard pour tutoyer au
confinement et tout ça donc le programme
a réellement démarré en 2021 et donc
pour le coup depuis 1 depuis un an
globalement on suit aujourd'hui près de
600 ménages dans le cadre de cette
action 600 ménages en martinique en
martinique oui oui à wii party 600
ménages d'accord alors justement est-ce
que c'est encourageant pour les uns et
pour les autres je veux dire à la fois
pour vous et pour ces personnes
sévèrement concernés oui directement
puisque l'objectif au-delà de l'acte
citoyen évidemment pour nous d'un pacte
et et facture énergétique de nos ménages
puisque vous savez que souliers antilles
aujourd'hui voilà s'occupe du relogement
des ménages martiniquais en mobilisant
le parc privé mais surtout les plus
fragiles d'entre eux donc l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est d'essayer d'augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat de ses ménages ce
sont des ménages particulier ciblé pour
ça et qui ont de faibles revenus qui
sont dans des situations non aujourd'hui
le budget du particulièrement difficile
aujourd'hui le programme ne concerne pas
des gens sous plafond de ressources
particulièrement en situation de
difficultés financières ou uniquement
puisqu'il s'adresse aussi aux
propriétaires bailleurs propriétaires
occupants et aux ménages
voilà sans condition de ressources
l'idée c'est que tous participent à
cette réduction en fait d'aider des
problématiques énergétiques et fasse des
économies d'énergie pour voilà pour
impacter ses problématiques qui ces
problématiques climatiques que nous
connaissons quoi alors vous avez fait
allusion à des ateliers ludiques des
visites à domicile gratuite aussi un
atout ménage par par principe donc
comment comment s'opère donc les
conseils pour aider à à moins et donc
mieux consommer aussi et l'objectif
final étant de réduire les factures
énergétiques on l'a dit voilà bah en
fait les ménages sont accompagnés
individuellement
dans le cadre d'une enquête qui
réalisait avec eux notamment sur leur
façon d'utiliser leur appareillage leurs
actes au quotidien
et en fait ils sont conseillés sur sur
les meilleures attitudes la meilleure
attitude à adopter de manière à réduire
en fait cet impact donc il ya des années
d'efforts
on leur montre bien je viens jeux
interactifs aussi ces ménages comment
sont-ils repérer ces des volontaires qui
se présentent spontanément c'est vous
qu'il est qu'il est ciblé à travers des
organismes partenaires comme en mai ce
sont les deux c'est à dire qu'en fait
d'une manière générale cela a pour
objectif aussi d'accompagner les ménages
qui sont dans son parc donc déjà en fait
cela sont ciblées envers delà de ça en
fait nous avons des actions collectives
donc voilà sur le territoire
martiniquais
nous informons aussi au travers des
associations qui accompagnent le public
d'une manière générale et donc du coup
c'est tout azimut que nous essayons de
faire prendre conscience de ces
problématiques et si on d'impact est en
fait les revenus de ces ménages
martinique alors il faut bien comprendre
aussi que l'intérêt de ça c'est un
programme
d'accompagnement ce2 cet effet qu'à
d'économie d'énergie donc l'idée c'est
d'essayer d'augmenter aussi le confort
énergétique des logements qui sont qui
sont en martinique et donc de faire
prendre conscience aussi au travers de
conseils apportés aux propriétaires de
l'intérêt de faire ça tombe de travaux
en fait sur lesquels nous pouvons les
accompagner en terme de montage
financier pour que ce confort thermique
s'améliore et que derrière en fait voilà
ça sera un ensemble qui qui permettent
ces économies d'énergie sur le
territoire alors ce qu'un programme
labellisé par l'état qui est déployé sur
six territoires d'outre-mer dont la
martinique mais dites moi à ce moment de
notre échange galerie pallade et
directeur général chez celui des
antilles qu'à l'intérêt pour pour total
et même pour vous ceux liés à antilles
on a bien compris qu'il ya un intérêt
d'économie d'énergie pour les ménages
mais bon mental c'est un grand groupe
industriel français qui est qui cherche
quand même aussi un peu de rentabilité
oui vous aussi vous avez votre chiffre
d'affaires voilà oui mais en fait tu lis
aujourd'hui les pourvoyeurs d'énergie
que son total ont des obligations en
fait inscrire dans la loi climat
résilience qui permet qui lorsqu'ils les
oblige vous faites aujourd'hui à
financer en fait un certain nombre
d'actions
dont on fête ses actions d'information
publique et d'accompagnement des publics
qui recadre un peu contraignant quand
même qui pousse clairement l'entreprise
voilà voilà donc l'idée c'est une
compensation en fait de leur bilan
carbone au travers de ces de ses
financements et ça se traduit par un
laisser-aller certificats d'économie
d'énergie qui sont là aujourd'hui pour
financer un certain nombre d'actions
notamment aussi je parlais en termes de
roues donc d'information au public mais
aussi en terme de travaux sur sur cette
compensation de bilan carbone qu'ils ont
quoi
quelques mots sur des partenariats que
vous avez notamment dont comme on la
dirait que les centres communaux
d'action sociale
d'autres partenaires aussi d'un oui
évidemment la trisomie sociale et
solidaire l'ademe et puis je vous disais
tout le réseau associatif aujourd'hui
qui encadrent un donc les ménages que ce
soit dans les quartiers où
autres au travers du ccas comme on le
disait oui on travaille aussi que les
épiceries solidaires
des associations familiales unaf et puis
grâce à deux familles et bien d'autres
alors pour conclure guipavas des parce
que votre objectif est de toucher alors
25 mille ménages ne sais pas si ça
concerne la martinique seulement non
c'est 25 ménages c'est sur l'ensemble du
territoire ultramarin est donc pour nous
on voit là ça représente entre 7000 et
10 mille ménages en martinique
l'objectif était de toucher donc ici
entre sept et dix mille ménages d'ici
décembre 2022 comment ce programme s
va-t-il se déclinait pour pour la suite
en cette année justement déjà compte
tenu des retards pris par le confinement
et autre ben finalement nous avons
obtenu une année supplémentaire ça veut
dire qu'on ira certainement jusqu'en
juin 2000 23 sur le déploiement de ce
programme donc ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle puisqu'il est complètement
gratuit rappelons le pour l'ensemble des
bénéficiaires et il va toujours
continuer à se décliner sur la forme des
actions de je vous ai parlé donc des éco
gestes des ateliers des jeux qui sont
proposés et évidemment ce qui est
important pour nous soit là les pisans
en fait chez les individus chez les
ménages de manière à les aider
appréhendé en fait cette
problématique oui c'est ça passe quand
un objectif final et c'est notre
dernière question pour cette première
partie ces deux c'est d'arriver jusqu'au
diagnostic ciblée et adaptée aux besoins
de près ce que chacun des ménages
menacés cas par cas quasiment ses cinq
amies nastic individuel ce qui fait qu
effectivement lors de
lors de l'entretien avec le ménage voilà
ce sont ses habitudes de consommation
qui sont appréhendés évidemment on a
aussi une lecture de son appareillage de
manière à faire en sorte que derrière
les économies seraient réalisées et puis
un suivi en fait sur un certain nombre
de temps c'est à dire que même après la
fin de l'action pendant un an ses
médailles seront encore suivi ah oui il
ya un accompagnement voilà qu'on a fait
jusqu'à quelle proportion de d'économie
d'énergie en pourcentage par exemple
pour certains mais n'est ce pas vous
donner une idée parce que ça parle plus
aux gens en terme en termes de tarifs
voilà ça ça ça peut être entre 80 et 200
euros par an réaliser des économies le
ménage d'économies voilà pendant 80 et
200 voix la sas puisque c'est à dire
pendant typologie familial ça dépend de
la superficie du logement voilà donc ça
peut pas être précis mais voilà c'est
une fourchette qui est quand même assez
importante pour qu'elle puisse
susciter l'intérêt et l'adhésion de la
bien vous le rappellerai tout à l'heure
comment il faut faire si on souhaite
s'inscrire dans une
tout à l'heure gary pas parader après
cette courte interruption du mythe